Bloopers are just a part of doing business
when that business is show business.
Actors are bound to mess up a line every now
and then, or, after a long day on set, improvise
and make their co-stars laugh.
While most of these flubs and goofs are innocent,
some are downright raunchy.
For example...
Full House
Has there ever been a more innocuous TV show
than Full House?
The often sickeningly-sweet sitcom used its
"awwwwwww" track almost as often as its laugh
track.
But two of its cast members were veteran stand-ups,
both quick on their feet… and even occasionally
pretty filthy.
In this blooper, Dave Coulier really lets
Bob Saget have it, but apologizes to another
character, off-camera…
"I can really see how little your d--- is
in that suit."
"Sorry, Patty."
"'Sorry, Patty?'
How about, 'Sorry Bob?'
'Bob's got a real small weiner!
Sorry, Patty.'"
Friends
The friends of Friends were, well, friends.
And when people are that close, both in friendship
and proximity, there's bound to be the occasional
bit of accidental nudity.
It's even a plot line that was actually scripted
on Friends at least a couple of times — but
this is not one of those times…
"One hand on the sheet, Joe.
"You saw it didn't you?"
"Yeah, I saw it."
The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
In this blooper from the otherwise classy
sitcom The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air, Carlton
is supposed to be concentrating really hard
— but he looks like he's doing something
else … so somebody in the sound booth "sweetened"
the shot …
"Go on, try it."
The Soupy Sales Show
Soupy was a beloved kiddie TV host in the
early days of TV.
But one day, his crew surprised him in the
middle of a taping with an R-rated special
guest behind an on-set door …
"Beautiful!"
"Get out of here."
"Right now, let's have a couple of commercials."
30 Rock
Will Arnett had a recurring role on 30 Rock
as Devon Banks, a nefarious and sometimes
predatory NBC executive with his eye on the
innocent page, Kenneth.
His "flirting" could get a little creepy and
alarming, such as when he force-fed Kenneth
a bottle of apple juice, and Arnett's riffing
got a little out-of-hand ...
"God your mouth is so thirsty.
Such a thirsty mouth."
Better Off Ted
This quirky ABC sitcom aired for just two
seasons, but it quickly became a cult hit
for its surreal and twisted take on office
culture.
In one episode, a typo in a memo requires,
rather than discourages, employees of the
show's workplace to use "offensive or insulting"
language.
This led to some pretty insane outtakes as
the actors and writers kept trying to one-up
each other.
Here's just a sample …
"I'm terrible at insults."
"I can help you, you mouse-humping piece of
s---."
"I can help you, you sweaty thong in a hooker's
money crack."
"Could you repeat that in English?
I don't speak the language of the square-jawed
c-- puppets."
Parks and Recreation
A tremendous cast of comedy all-stars kept
things loose and improvised from time to time
on the set of NBC's small-town government
comedy, Parks and Recreation.
But Chris Pratt, in particular, had a difficult
time not crossing the line, such as in this
scene where the gang pretends to be old people
to better empathize with them ...
"When I sit down to do my dirty business,
my gonads hangle [sic] in the water."
"Hangle?"
"Sorry about that.
'They hangle in the water!'"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!